busy Friday President Trump firing up
his base today with a rousing speech at
CPAC outside Washington DC he addressed
a number of pressing issues including
the crisis in our schools North Korea
and also the upcoming elections hoping
to motivate the crowd not to be
complacent about the midterms
historically if you win the presidency
you do you don't do well two years later
and you know what we can't let that
happen
don't be complacent because if they get
in they will repeal your tax cuts they
will put judges in that you wouldn't
believe they'll take away your Second
Amendment which we will never allow to
happen they'll take away you sector the
moment they will take away those massive
tax cuts and they will take away your
second amendment the Senate Democrats
and the House Democrats have totally
abandoned acha they've totally they
don't even talk to me about it they have
totally abandoned you know we get the
reputation like Daka it's not Republican
don't worry you're getting the wall
don't worry okay hurts
[Applause]
there was of course lots of trademark
Trump flash as well all those horrible
people back there they go to support me
you know why because if somebody else
won their ratings would go down that'll
be out of business my administration I
think has had the most successful first
year in the history of the presidency I
really believe that we have a very very
crooked median
when I was here 2011 I made a speech it
was there was a love fest 2011 I believe
the time was and a lot of people
remembered and they said we want Trump
we want John by the way what a nice
picture that is look at that I'd love to
watch that guy speak
[Applause]
I try like hell to hide that bald spot
folks I work harder does it look bad hey
Wang it in we're hanging it
I thought Greg that was the best moment
it's so self-deprecating
for someone that's pretty I wouldn't say
vain but it's very involved with his
hair this is recent but he's really good
at taking the slings and the arrows and
turning them into armor so it's like
it's very difficult you were talking to
me about this new Stephen Colbert
cartoon about trumpet how hard it is for
anti-trump comedians to prosper because
Trump himself is actually more
interesting cartoons not that funny yeah
because the UK you're competing with
that she's funny that's actually funnier
so it's like imagine a portrait class
where everybody's painting an athlete
but all they can do her stick figures
that's what's happening you can't make
he's better at doing this than everybody
else I would say he's adept at it but I
did feel like watching this that I was
like at you know Ruth's Chris because
there was so much red meat but that's
the audience that watched it when you're
going to when you're going to CPAC you
give the red meat but the only
difference is he's interesting and he's
funny I mean the Democrats could use
some of that very entertaining we think
the Democrats are funnier Greg for
different we're laughing at them not
with them he was there obviously too you
know tout his accomplishments to also
fire up the base because it's going to
be a base election and traditionally you
know the party in power doesn't do well
do you think he effectively you know
created any momentum for the crowd there
absolutely but in the larger context
well yeah I think he has the three big
things they the accomplishments he's
gonna point to our tax reform and the
economy yep the judges yep
for this crowd in particular and then
and then I think he would say his second
Amendment protections that's not really
a proactive thing that he did but they
love that those are the three things
that he kept repeating and it's not so
much a prospective thing like look at
all the things we're going to do this
year in 2018 that's what he said last
year look over here
20:17 because there's really nothing
that they're really going to be able to
get done I don't think immigrations
gonna get done and I just saw John
Cornyn has just put out a statement
saying he does not agree with the
President on raising the age of the
weapons to 21 I'm getting a weapon to 21
and so you already see that peeling off
in the Senate so the prospective things
aren't going to work right telling that
crowd that if the Democrats win they're
gonna take away the tax cuts they're
going to try to take away the judges
that you have and they're gonna try to
repeal the Second Amendment well you
better go out there and vote the other
thing the only thing about this Beach
and I've said this a lot is that I feel
like he could drive a new cycle better
if he chose one thing to drive news on
at the top of the speech let the
network's and all the reporters cover
that piece and then move on to do the
rest of the speech because he everything
gets lost it was like being a truth
Chris with like five course meal and I
couldn't I couldn't eat it all so again
the big news I think what you would say
was the North Korea sanctions that he
left to the very end I almost think he
might have even forgotten he was gonna
break the North Korean section news
because there was so much other stuff
and he also spoke to reporters before he
even got to the event and I see what you
mean about diluting the message Juan
what was the most offensive part of this
seven years to go heart attack
my guess what he said seven years ago
the seatback audience went Wow so this
was a rally that's what I thought it was
gonna be and I think his staff thought
it was going to be something about
increasing sanctions on North Korea as
you say he's kind of got to it at the
very end but as an afterthought he was
far more interested in to pick up on the
steak house analogy of throwing out the
chunks of red meat everywhere he turned
I was surprised that he was throwing out
chunks though that had to do with things
like Democrats abandoned dacha I'm the
one who cared wait a minute he's the one
who ended dacha and set this March
deadline now he finds himself in a
situation the deadlines approaching and
he's got nothing and the Democrats are
willing to take a risk I hope they're
having a little more spine than they did
last time when schumer backed out on
that budget deal and then this business
about locker up Jesse
it just seems to me like you know what
would you say Greg that's a 1970s hit
you know I mean we've been through that
and he won't say he's still it's his
Freebird classic rose that was a that
was the best night he needs a Hillary he
needs an Obama because he's not he just
needs somebody to be tired but Kimberly
I think every politician has a boogeyman
out there whether it's at home or abroad
that they use to score points against
and Hillary continues to be out there in
the conversation so why not take a shot
she lost he loses it's like Groundhog
Day for every day she gets uppity remind
no no I like you like Pelosi the boogie
person I stand corrected the boogie
person yes and yeah but the crowd loves
it they love it they're like oh okay
lock her up they go crazy you know he
doesn't say her stuff you'd like the
snake poems that's the next you know so
this is like classic quintessential
president Trump this is how he speaks
every time he gets up in front of
somebody it's a rally opportunity yep
you know so and he obviously did very
well with the crowd there they loved him
and he loves them back and he said that
at the end they said I love you guys
have you been the seatback right yeah I
spoke there's like five years yeah
there's one thing to that we didn't have
I don't think we had in the montage
where he was explaining what happens
after you win an election
yeah and how like yeah you just won and
then like a year later you got it it's
really hard I don't remember any
president ever saying that that was
human psyche no that's human psychology
101 he was explaining why you lose in
two years in a way that people at home
understands like it's so much work you
already won and I'm gonna like that's
the best it's so persuasive I think
you're looking at me like this is
evidence of how little he knows politics
or how little preparation he had for the
Japanese never been a center he never
been a governor never been a congressman
and he comes oh this is really hard
who knew health care could be so
complicated subject of ridicule least
that's honest when he said when he said
that we're working on policies that are
good for our enemies are you insane
enemies but our opponents and they don't
even they might not even realize that
these policies are good for them but
we're doing them anyway I thought that
was kind of effective
yeah what's effective he had a few nice
things he said about keeping his promise
Kimberly he bragged obviously about he's
like you know the only politician that's
actually kept war promises and he made
during the campaign but when you look
back besides the wall a lot of the stuff
he has delivered on and the audience
really enjoyed that they did and because
I think they feel like he's you know
kind of a man of the people even though
he's you know a New York billionaire
he's relatable because the his language
his rhetoric isn't like flowery it's
very like down-to-earth
it's like relatable to the average man
and woman everyone there's something for
everybody there with like you know what
this is my guy he's not trying to talk
above me he's not trying to talk around
me making me feel like I'm here for you
we've got things in common I'm getting
it done and so that's like a reassuring
feeling it's not like the typical
politician where you go I can't relate
to that person at all can i play skunk
at the garden party for just a second
I think I think he promised to do away
with Obamacare oh yeah I think I think
Obamacare so real that Scott Walker in
Wisconsin is now even thinking about
back it's a real yes then he says oh I
think we should have infrastructure oh I
don't see any infrastructure spending on
not oh no no Democrats could come I
promise to cut the deficit the minute I
get in there we're gonna cuts
interesting is that it you know you it's
amazing to see Democrats carrying about
a deficit Trump did that to him but if
the thing about what Kimberly says and
what Dana says and what want says as the
presentation is an old-school populist
gets up there he's telling you this is
what we're gonna do but wouldn't you
pull back the reason why none of us all
go like we have disagreements all of us
do is because almost everything he does
is common sense centrism if you look at
his immigration stance he talks about
enforce border but he's also talking
about 1.7 million people he talks about
guns he's talking about practical
proactive solutions that some that meant
might even enter an array might not like
tax reform it didn't help if people
think that really helped the rich
they're wrong today it wasn't in the
CPAC speech but in his press conference
with Martin Turnbull
he talked briefly but it was an
interesting insight into that he is
getting the briefings and he understands
what's happening in Syria and he said it
was disgraceful within 250 innocent
people that we know of were killed
targeted by Russians and Syrians and we
have a huge mess on our hands they're
the one thing that I think is a little
bit different difficult to understand is
okay so he says that but also in the
same speech or the press conference he
says you know we have degraded Isis
we've taken away their territory and
we're out of there yep and that is not
sustainable though both of those things
cannot be true so I think going forward
in a second year of a presidency your
foreign policy pieces get really
important and a little bit more
difficult to deal with you know one
right just before we go it's kind of a
serious note but there
stories now that indicate the Russians
were in touch with top leadership before
they attacked it's the same guy it's
been the problem yeah that's that report
is terrible you could tell that the
president knew about it and then he was
talking about it